This creepy Deli in New Jersey is hiding  a dark secret on the outside this Deli  was barely scraping by it sold less than  60 dollars worth of food a day but on  the inside the owners were using this  Deli from the most insane case of fraud  ever using fake accounts the owners sold  Company stock to each other over and  over again to pump the price of this  Deli stock to the moon and investors  fell for it what started out as a dollar  and 25 cents per share for this Deli  skyrocketed to over 13 a share making  this ghetto Place earned the nickname of  the if Miss 100 million dollar Deli but  at least the Philly cheesesteak was good  subscribe to watch our full-length  documentary on this coming out soon